hello everyone and welcome to this
advanced python fill course by simply
learn
in this field course we will be covering
some advanced python concepts that are
important for developers
in this video we will be discussing
about iterators
modules packages generators list
comprehensions followed by that
we will work on regular expressions
serializations
partial functions closures decorators
map filter and reduce functions and
towards the end
we will be working on a small project
based on our learnings
we have anish with us who's been working
with the industry for a very long time
he will be helping us to learn the
in-depth concepts in
python and he will also explain us how
to code efficiently
over to you anish hello everyone and
welcome to another video on python
programming
in this video we will be covering the
topic of iterators
now an iterator in python is an object
that contains a countable number of
values
or it's a larger object that contains a
countable number of sub-objects
an iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon
and what that means is we can traverse
from each value and we can
manipulate or perform certain functions
or operations and tasks
using each of the sub-objects or values
within
this larger collection called iterator
now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
python which consists of the methods
eter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we're going to traverse through
the objects of a list
using the for loop so we have objects
one two three four and i'm going to
print each of these values one by one
as you can see here similarly we can
also do the same thing for another
iterable
known as the string where we can go
character by character again using the
for loop
as you can see here another example of
an iterable in python is the dictionary
so let's say i have a dictionary where i
have two values two key value pairs
uh key x which contains the value one
and key y which
corresponds to the value two now when
i'm going to do a for loop through this
by default
i will be traversing through the keys x
and y as you can see over here
and of course the other types of weight
troubles in python are like
sets and tuples as well all right now
let's look at
what this iterating protocol is in
python
so first of all we take an iterable it's
an object that contains uh it's a
collection of objects that contain sub
objects
and when we use the eater function it
creates an iterator out of it so we can
one by one we can traverse through um
each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects
that is contained in this and uh anytime
we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when
we have finally completed all of the or
we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub objects we
encountered the stop iteration exception
which tells us okay there are no more
objects to be manipulated or
iterated upon so and as an example i
will create a list
where i will store the values uh some
simple values integers one two three
four one three four five okay um i'm
going to create an iterator out of this
where i will use
it function and i'm going to say this is
let's say this is called
my my heater okay
and i'm going to use iter function as i
had mentioned and i'm going to pass my
list in this
now if you see what is my eter it should
say it should be a
list iterator at a particular memory
location now let's use the next function
to keep going through whatever is there
in this
so of course the first object should be
one as you can see
now when i look at the next it should be
3 then i should get 4
and now i should get 5 as i use the next
successively
now since i've reached the last of my
objects in this collection
now the next time i use this next
function i should get a stop
stop iteration exception that is raised
as you can see here
so this is the basic um iteration
protocol in python now you might have uh
already gone through the for loop video
and in that i have spoken
in quite a bit of detail as to how a for
loop performs this
this iterator protocol and how it
creates an
iterative iterable object out of say a
list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function
and it breaks out of the for loop once
it encounters the stop iteration
exception
so um for loops are like they're very
very uh similar to
your standard iterator and they use
pretty much the same
protocol for its functioning now let's
do a basic comparison of what is a
a basic comparison between a generator
and an iterator in python
so in generator we use a function we use
like we define it
using the def keyword and we define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function
the generator makes use of the yield
keyword whereas the
python iterator does not in generators
we save the states of the local
variables
each time we use the yield keyword and
we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables
all we need is any trouble like a list
to iterate upon
we may use any number of yield
statements in generators and we do not
use
yield statements initiators generators
are not memory efficient whereas
iterators are very memory efficient so
this is like basic uh
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in python
now a module in python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a python program can use one or
more modules
and modules can have one or more
functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files or several modules
now
modular programming is the process of
breaking a large
a large event or task into smaller and
more manageable
subtasks and we call these subtasks
basically modules now individual modules
can be grouped together like building
blocks to create a larger
application there are several advantages
to modulizing code
in a large application and we will be
going through them right now first of
all there is simplicity
because instead of focusing on a big big
problem a big task we can break down the
problem into
smaller smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through modules because they are
designed to create these sort of
boundaries
or clear demarcations between different
problem domains
there is usability usability in the
sense that once we create a module we
can use it in different parts of the
code or even different different
applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically
define a separate namespace and this
helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program
functions modules and packages are
basically all constructs in python that
promote
code module modularization you might
have already come across
a gordon intro into functions in this
video we will be
going through modules in another video
we will also cover the topic of packages
to import a module
we use the import keyword and in this
example what i'm going to show you
is a simple function or a simple
operation of importing the os module
this is short for operating system and
as the name suggests we can perform
system tasks through the functions and
methods that are part of this
os module so simply executing the
statement will import this module
onto our program for us to use now if we
wanted to see all the functions that are
present in a module what we have to do
is use
the dir function so if we print the dir
os function
it will print us basically a directory
of all the functions that are present in
the os
module as you can see here like all of
these are basically uh
names to different functions that are
part of the os module
finally moving on another function
commonly used with modules
is the get cwd function and what this
does is it will give us the current
working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now
so if i execute this it will tell me
what is the directory that i am
currently working upon right now
as you can see seed notebook dir slash
10. if we wanted to see all the files in
a particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function
followed by giving a path by default if
we do not enter a path
inside the parenthesis it will basically
give us all the files in the current
working directory
which in our case is temp so if i were
to execute this it gives basically gives
me a list of all the files
that are presently there in the
directory that i am currently working
upon now a basic step
is um creating a python module the
simplest way to create a python module
is
basically creating a python script with
whatever functions and tasks that we
want
and methods that we want inside whatever
module
and saving it with a dot py extension um
so in in my example what i'm going to do
is i have already created a script
in notepad and i've stored it with a dot
py extension that contains these four
functions add
subtract product and division um i have
basically copied i basically use this
code and i've stored it in a dot py
script and i'm going to be using this
as my uh as as a test module for this
particular example
now how do we import a module now once
that i have created a script
uh in my example will be called my calc
dot py
and we've stated stored it in our
directory to import the module all we
have to do is use the import statement
so if i have to import my calc all i
have to do is
say import my underscore calc and
now my calc has been imported um so we
can use the import statement or if we
want to import something particular from
mycalc we can do
from my calc import now
whatever like for example if we wanted
the add uh
the add function we can basically just
say only add
or if we wanted add and subtract we can
say add and subtract
for example so this is basically by
using from we can say that we want
something from something but only parts
of it we don't want everything
we can also use from mycalc import and
we can say asterix
to basically say uh import everything
that exists in mycalc
right now so this is another way of
importing something from a module now to
access contents in a module we have to
use the dot operator and i will show you
how right now so
what i'm going to do is in my example
i'm going to import my calc as calc
so now what this since this is the
original folder or the original module
but i'm going to give it a shorthand
name so that i can easily use it in my
code and i don't have to type out my
underscore calc every time so now i'm
going to import this
as calc so anytime i have to refer to a
particular method or function
inside this script or this module i will
just use this uh
this placeholder this variable name so
now i have two variables a and b
and i'm storing 20 and 30 in them so my
first func what i'm going to do is
basically four operations
i'm going to print the addition of a and
b then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and
each time to do this operation i am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc
module so to do that i have already
imported my characters calc
all i am going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that
we're already familiar with
so i'm going to say calc dot add and
then i'm going to pass these two
arguments or these two variables
to say that i want to add these two and
similarly i'm going to do it for
subtraction
um multiplication and division as you
can see these are the results of my
tasks now if i had to do a directory
uh operation on the module calc it will
basically give me
a bunch of inbuilt or dunder methods
that
are already a part of any python script
by default such as built-ins
so if i execute this just to show you
what happens when i use the dir function
it will basically give me
all the functions that are part of this
python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh
denoting magic methods or dunder methods
and these are
like inbuilt methods as a part of the
script and if you see here add
division prod and sub these are the
methods that we have defined earlier on
in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
in more detail into what happens when we
do a module search um let's let's
actually look at what happens
so what happens is when for example we
execute the statement
import mycalc as calc as we did over
here so the first the steps that
actually take place are the interpreter
executes the above statement
and it searches for this python script
in a list of directories assembled from
these following sources that you see
here so
it takes the directory from which the
input script was run
or the current directory if the
interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now
secondly it will list all the
directories contained in the python path
environment that you set up that you can
set up or you can change later on as
well and this format for python path
is os dependent of course but it should
mimic the path environment variable that
we see in
windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories
configured at the time python is
installed now the resulting search path
that is accessible in the python
variable system.path
this is basically obtained from a module
named sys so if i imported this this and
i did sys.path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for
when we want to search for any
particular module so if i'm doing
uh import my kayak or import os it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that i'm working on
it's also going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as
you could say directories or paths in
the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages
now what if we developed a very large
application in python that contains many
different modules
and we have so many different modules
that have similar names and
functionalities
and they're all kept in like or dumped
in the same location that it becomes
very difficult to track these modules
what if there was a way to organize and
access these in a much
simpler and more organized manner well
packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation
and this is the same dot notation that
we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules
so let's try to let's look at certain
examples to understand what we mean
so i have a directory called pkg this
can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod one dot py and mod two dot p
by
and what we're going to store in mod one
and mod two dot p py are the follows
so i'm going to define a function called
foo and i'm going to print
this particular statement mod 1 and then
i'm going to basically say
foo and then i'm going to say in class 4
i'm going to have an empty pass command
similarly i'm going to define a function
called bar
in mod 2 dot py where i'm going to print
this statement so basically mod 1 dot py
has a simple function where i'm going to
print this statement and mod 2 dot py
has a simple function then i'm going to
print this statement
and i'm going to store them in mod 1 and
mod 2 dot py respectively
and these two modules i'm going to store
in the directory pkg
in my local folder now i've already done
this so we can already get
to working with this now if i wanted to
access these
particular modules from the pkg folder i
can simply use the import command
and use the dot notation so i can say
pkg.mod1 so this will inward
this will import the mod1 module from
pkg folder
similarly i can do the same thing for
the mod 2 module from the pkg folder in
the same line
so now that it's been imported just
simply execute this and this
imports whatever you needed now if we
wanted to
perform a function that was a part of
mod1 or py
we can just extend the dot notation and
use the function
as over here as you can see it performs
this print command whatever it was
supposed to do
similarly i can invoke the function that
was part of the mod
2 module by extending the dot notation
to it
in the same way now another way that i
can invoke
i can import a package is by directly
importing the package itself by using
import
pkg and not accessing any of the
specific modules within it now let's see
what happens when we do this
so just for this example what i'm going
to do is i'm going to restart the kernel
so that the pkg modules that were
already imported
get cleaned away so we see what happens
when we execute this on its own
now if you see i haven't imported this
now let's see if i can access
my mod 1 and mod 2. now if you see here
it's throwing me an error and this is
because
using simply using the import command on
a particular package
only imports you could say the package
namespace
but it does not actually import any of
the
modules and files that were part of this
package so if i wanted mod 1
from this package i would have to
actually say import pkg.mod 1 directly
and i cannot simply say import pkg and
python will not import everything that
is part of a package on its own
i have to specify it myself specifically
now i'm going to create and i'm gonna i
mean i'm going to show you another
type of importing from a package using
the star operator
so i have this package pkg once again
now i'm going to store
um three i mean four different modules
within this package
mod one one one dot p by mod two two two
dot p by and i've already done this you
don't need to bother about
um seeing me doing it right now because
i've already
created these files and what i've done
is within mod one one one dot py
i've defined i've written this statement
and i've stored it in the python script
similarly i've created another python
script
script called mod 222 dot py and i have
basically written this in the code and
i've simply done this for mod 333 dot py
and i've done another for mod 4 dot py
now once i have done this i've stored
these python scripts
into my uh into my package or pkg
package so now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to create i'm going to execute
this command
if you see this from pkg dot mod 333
import start so once i execute this now
i'm going to say
print directory and print directory
basically will tell me all the functions
that exist in my current directory
if you see here there's this bias
function that was a part of mod 333
module
now if i change this and if if i
imported mod 111
and if i did the same thing you will see
foo has now been added as a part of
this direction directory and these are
all uh functions that were part of these
different modules where i'm importing
from and that is what the star function
does
what the star function will do is it
will basically tell python okay so the
statement is sync from pkg.mod111
so it's saying that um okay look into
this directory or this
package and find this module and in this
module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions
from a particular package and a
particular specific module within that
package
so yeah this was a very brief video on
packages in python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically
a an organized way of storing many
different modules
that we might have created in a very
large application
and these modules can be accessed using
the familiar.note notation that
we have used in other examples such as
methods when we were working with
classes and objects
in this video we will be taking an
introduction into the concept of
generators
so python provides a generator which is
like a
function where we can create our own
iterator in a generator function we use
the yield statement instead of
the return statement that we use for
standard functions
so let's look at a simple generator
first of all so out here i have defined
a generator called my generator where
i'm doing uh
like there are three uh like three
functions or three tasks that i'm doing
uh first one is when i'm printing the
first item
and i'm yielding a value 10 then i'm
printing second item yielding 20 then
i'm printing last item using 30.
so let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword
every time we use the next keyword we
will keep getting what is next in this
function
so let's store the generator
in my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable
called gen or gen now let's see when we
do
next and we use
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first
iteration is performed where we get this
the first yield command is done
all right let's see what happens when we
do next again
gen now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20.
let's do it for the next let's do it
once more since there is one more task
there's one more iterable inside you can
see this now a valid question is what
will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this well
let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another
built-in exception that happens when we
have like reached the last
object of an iterable so we get a stop
iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator
and a function is that when we execute a
function
the moment we hit the return statement
in a function
or when we execute a function like
whatever variables that were stored
inside are lost
and they are destroyed unless they were
defined as global
and the function is completely done
executing and we leave the function
completely
whereas when it comes to a generator
when we hit the yield function
we don't actually completely leave this
function so the first time the yield is
found
we get 10 but the generator remembers
its position inside this function
so the next time we use the next we
actually
move on to the next iterable and then we
move on to the next iterable
so you can think of a generator as it
sort of has memory
if that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in python
or create iterators in python so to
understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return command does
let's take the same function all right
and let's put a return over here after
this particular
the second yield okay let's do the same
thing
we say gen is equal to my
generator and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing is there so
the first deal will be standard first
item 10
the next one is again is going to say
second item and then 20
but now if you notice there was a return
i put over here
so technically when i did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function
or this return statement so let's see
what happens if i do next again
as you see i have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than i did
before
and that's because i have used the
return function and our in return
statement and what that's done is
that um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration
and that's uh the difference between
yield and return
now in the next example i'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of
the for loop or for a for loop so let's
take this
whatever over here and i have defined a
function called get sequence up to x
and what this will do is basically it
will keep printing the
printing numbers up until whatever we
have entered in place of x over here
so if i said say sequence is equal to
let's uh
copy this all right and say i want um
i want sequentially i want every number
up until 10 well not including 10 of
course
because python starts with zero right so
let's do this
and um now let's see
so the first number will yield 0
and now if i did this again
it should give me 1 2 and i can keep
going
until i will stop at the value 9
as you can see here so 8
9 now i should get the stop iteration
error
because that we have reached the end of
our iteration
so this is a way of using generator
functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator
is in the case of fibonacci numbers
so let's use it let's see how we can
generate a fibonacci series using um
generator so i've defined a fibonacci
function
called fibonacci where i'm passing max
so max is basically the
max value that i want um yeah like up
until where i want the sequence right
so this is basically the code which will
give you return me the subsequent values
of my fibonacci sequence
so let's pass this to fib
and say i want all the fibonacci numbers
until 10
so and i will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with 0 then when we
do this again we get one then we do zero
plus one
it should be one next number should be
one plus one which is two
then we should have two plus one three
and then three plus two
five then 3 plus 5 should be 8. now 8
plus 5 is
13 and since 13 is greater than what we
passed for our max value here
now when we try this we should get the
stop iteration error as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
now list comprehension is it's a neat
way of
creating a new list based on values that
are already there in
an existing list so you can think of it
like
creating a new list using a much shorter
and cleaner syntax compared to
what you might traditionally be thinking
so let's go through some examples
and through those examples we will see
how list comprehension makes
creating these new this much simpler
much easier for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list
which will contain fruits that contain
the letter a in their
name so we already have a list of fruits
over here as you can see
it has apple it has banana cherry kiwi
and mango
now we want to create a new list which
has only the fruits that have the letter
a inside them so
apple would be one of them banana would
be one of them and
mango would be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code this
would do what we want to do but this
contains a few
extra lines but yeah it does it does do
what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that exists as you can
see here
so i take the same
list now this is where you need to
follow
so now my new list is equal to so i'm
creating a list over here as you can see
now within this list you have this line
this is what we call a list
comprehension
so as you can see it says each fruit for
each fruit in fruits if now it's
checking for the letter or the character
a
inside each fruit and what this each
fruit is
that we're checking each object in this
list one by one
so first in the first iteration each
fruit will contain
the string apple then in the next
iteration it will contain banana
and in each each iteration we are going
to check if it contains
the character a and if it does then we
store
that each fruit in the new list as you
can see here so if i execute this line
you see
my my result is the same i have my
whatever i wanted
and this was a much cleaner way of
writing or
creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what i'm going to do
is i am going to iterate through a
string
so i have a string it can be anything in
this case i am using a string called
human
all right so i have a string called
human right
now i want to store each character of
this string into a
list that we call etch underscore
letters so if i use the for loop this is
how we would do it
if i execute this as you can see the
list contains h
and then u m a and then n now what if i
wanted to do the same thing but
uh by using list comprehension so
what i would do is let's create
a list over here let's underscore
letters
and um so as we know list com
so a list comprehension will uh it's
it's a
so you just basically need one line in
this case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when i check what's in
edge letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see i have
the output as uh what i needed so this
is a
much cleaner way let's go through some
more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we
have already seen uh one case where we
checked for the character a
we've seen a case where we went through
where we
we did a sort of a loop through a string
we can also use
this comprehensions in conditionals so
let's uh look at an example where
we use the uh this comprehension with an
if statement
so what if i wanted to store say the
first 10
even numbers so this would so this is an
example that i'll be using
so in my list i want to store the first
10 even numbers so this would be a way
to do it
so i have in range 20. so what this is
going to do is
x is going to take the value of 1 2 3 4
and so on until 98 either actually take
it from 0
1 2 3 4 until 19. so when we do range 20
we're creating an
iterate in iterable where uh
we're going to loop through our iterate
through the value of 0 to 19.
so if i if i do this and this what this
statement does is basically it checks if
it's divisible by 2.
so if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number
and if this condition is met if this
condition is met that means we store
the x into our number list so let's see
what happens when we execute this
it should contain uh 0 2 4 6
until 18 so this is the first and even
numbers as you can see
so this is a neat way of using if
statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if five i'm checking um each
okay so i'm going to create another list
and in this list i'm going to
basically see if each of my
uh num numbers either even or odd the
first
let's say 10 natural numbers so let's
write this statement down
so i want it to be even in case
the i that i'm checking i being every
number between
so like say the first 10 natural numbers
as i said
let's check if um if it is divisible by
2
well if it divides by 2 of course it's
going to be even right
else we say that it is odd
and then we check for i in say the first
let's say the first 20
okay so now when we do this let me check
oh we check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even orders basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd and
number two is even and so on and so
forth so this is a
an example where we used the list
comprehension with uh if else statements
so another neat thing that we can do
with the
list comprehensions is that we can use
it along with functions
so let's look at this function in this
example we have a function called double
x where we define this double x
uh this double function to take an input
uh to take an argument x
and what we return is the square of the
argument
so let's use this in uh in our lifts
this comprehension
so what we do over here is that we are
we're checking
what we're doing is for every x um
bet in range 10 so we're taking the
value of 0 1 2 3 until 9
and we're passing it to this function
double x and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here
let's call this list uh x let's just
call this list
it's called y so now let's see what's in
y
and we check uh it should be 0 1
4 9 and so on so wait this let's check
again does this square no this is
actually
2 times so let's make it square as you
can see
so you can see 0 1 4 9 for the first
10 numbers 10 natural numbers now what
i've shown you is obviously
list comprehension but we can also do
set and dictionary comprehensions
in fact set comprehensions work exactly
the same way as
list comprehensions the only difference
is the
set comprehension will make sure that
there are no duplicates
inside the set so you can't have like
duplicate items
which you can in the case of list
comprehensions
so let's uh let's just take a look at an
example
so here in this example what we're doing
is we're going to check
so we have this string that we're
storing in the variable text
and the string is uh something like life
finds a way
so whatever this is now what we're going
to do is we're going to
uh in iterate through this string
character by character and we're going
to check if uh
there are we're going to check for
wobbles essentially so
uh we're going to see if the character a
e i
o or u is present in the string and if
it is we will pass it into our set
now if you if you look you will find
there are multiple i's right
and there are multiple a's as well so if
we did this through a list comprehension
each time that we found find a vowel
it would be added to our list but since
this is a set and sets do not allow
duplicates
so you will only have one copy or one
particular
object for each of the vowels so
uh of course now uh set comprehension is
defined using curly braces so let's keep
that in mind
so now if i check what's in this i will
see a e
i and u even though there are multiple
a's or multiple e's or
i's and u's since this is a set we don't
have duplicate copies of any copies of
any of these
uh so this was just a small example for
showing you set comprehensions
similarly we can do the same thing uh
this this comprehension
uh for dictionaries and we call the
dictionary comprehensions
the only thing that we have to worry
about when it comes to dictionary
comprehensions
is that we have to define a key when it
comes to this
so let's look at an example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces
just like sets except in this case
we will define a key and that separates
it from a set comprehension
so in this case what we're doing is that
i'm checking uh
i'm going through the a list of numbers
from zero to nine right so what the
range then function does
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a key
which is going to be like 0 1 2 3 and
the value of each key would be a square
as you can see here
i'm doing i times i or just to
make a little more clearer as you can
see i'm doing i square over here
for every value from 0 to 9 so
what i should get is like a dictionary
where
the first key is 0 and the value of that
key should be 0 as well because 0
square is 0. then for 1 it will be 1 and
then for 2
4 and then 3 9 4 16. so let's see what
happens
as you can see here this is the the
result that i wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to
list comprehensions um so it's obviously
an elegant way
uh to define and create lists based on
existing lists
it's more compact and faster than normal
functions and loops
but we should also keep in mind that we
shouldn't
write like very complicated list
comprehensions because
the idea of a list comprehension is to
be user friendly
and also it's important to note that
every list comprehension
can be written in the form of a loop but
every loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember so
yeah that's it uh this for this video on
list comprehension set comprehension
dictionary comprehensions
i hope you learned a new a neat new
technique or
trick when it comes to creating your new
list in this video we will be learning
about the concept of regular expressions
now a regular expression is simply a
sequence of characters that defines a
search pattern
for example if you see this example here
you can see a symbol called the carrot
followed by
p and then five periods then an
n and a dollar sign and what this regex
pattern does
is it's searching for a seven letter
string that starts with p
ends with n and has five characters in
between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for
a five character string that starts with
a ends with s and has three characters
in between
now if we had to match this with this
tree with these strings as an
as i or test strings the first one would
not match because it's a three letter
string and we're looking for a five
character string
the second one would match because it's
a five character string that
ends with an s starts with an a and has
three characters in between
this will not match because whatever
pattern would do is it would find the
first
s and it would find that it the string
itself starts with an a
and it would say okay there are only two
characters between this first s
and this a and it would assume that this
is actually just a four character string
to actually identify two consecutive s's
we would have to do something special
and what we would have to do is what we
will see later on
so again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive
capital a is perfectly fine when we're
searching for this
and it will also match this is this is
obviously
two words and it's not a five character
string so this will not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in python
can be imported using this statement
import re
now once we've done this we can actually
use
our regular expression tools and methods
to do
pattern recognition character
recognitions and to identify different
sequence of characters in our strings
let's try to understand a bit more in
depth about regular expressions now
so what you're seeing here is one
variable called pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex and
another variable that stores our test
string called abyss
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the match method
of this module re and we're going to
check
whether this pattern or whatever we are
trying to search using this regex
is in fact does it match with our test
string
and what we're trying to look for is if
you see here very similar to what i just
showed you
a five character string that starts with
a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it indeed
is a match
and when we use this uh this command we
should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if i execute
this
and this is what it does now if i change
the test string to
this now you will see that now this is
no longer
what we're looking for a five character
string with uh a and
starting with a and ending with s and
you will see that the search
will be unsuccessful as you can see here
now let's try to understand
what exactly do we mean by uh when we
use these different
certain these special symbols like for
example this carrot or this
dollar symbol um these are by the way
known as meta characters
and now we're going to look into all the
uh or most of the different
meta characters that are used in red x
so
to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way
by the regex search engine now here's
the list of meta characters
let's go through them one by one now the
square brackets
square bracket simply specify the set of
characters that we wish to match
so we want to match some combination of
a b and c it can be one a two a's three
b's
four c's we are not looking at a
specific pattern we just want to know if
a
b and c exists in any form in our string
so if we used it on a the string a
simply we would find one match because
the letter a is found here ac would
match twice because we have a
and c present here in this string hey
jude
we will have no matches because a b and
c none of them are found here
and in this weird string we will have
actually one two
three four and five matches
so we would have five matches for this
uh this bigger string
because we have five instances of a b or
c
now let's use re.match to
do to actually search for this and to
see if we have
our particular whatever patterns that
we're looking for
now in this input string this is just
some example string
i'm going to test this i'm going to
match whether my pattern
that um any of a b and c is it actually
found in this so let's see what happens
when i use re.match for this
so this is the format the syntax is
simply the regex pattern
and then comma whatever test string that
we have
so let's see what object gets created
when we try to do this
as you can see it's none even though you
might be wondering like
i can see an a over here i can see a c
over here
re.match actually gives us the result
none
now if i try to do it on this test
string
which is slightly different instead of
the film titanic was at least 1998 what
i'm saying here is all film titanic was
at least in 1998
now let's see if the r match works or
not
as you can see it actually does return
when i execute this it returns us an
object called
re.match object with a span01 the span01
is basically telling us
that we have found a match between the
zeroth and the first character which is
basically this character a
which is what it has found and it's
saying that the match is indeed the
character a
from amongst these options so what this
is basically telling us
and what this means actually is that
the re.match method will only
find matches if they occur at the start
of the string being searched
once there is a space in in our bigger
string it will not search for whatever
comes after it
so what happened in the first instance
was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word
in my largest string and since it found
no match it basically gave us the result
none
which was not the case in the second
example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter a
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be
using is the re.search
as you can see here the re.search method
will actually check the whole string and
uh it will return us the first
instance where it finds a match now
let's see
this is the test string now and we're
searching again for
our uh we're searching for a b and c any
any of these
in our test string but we're going to
use re.search and not match
so now if you see it returns us when i
execute this it returns us a match
object again
but this time it's saying the span of 9
and 10. now the spine panel 9 and 10
actually exists over here this is the
ninth character and a itself is the
tenth character
over here so what this basically is
telling us that the tenth character is
where we found a match
which was the letter a which was the
first instance of either a
or b or c in this whole string and this
is basically how re.search works
it will not only search the beginning of
the string but it will search the whole
string
and return us the first instance
wherever we find
now what if we wanted to find out all
the instances
wherever a b and c were found and not
just the first instance
but in that case we would be using the
method find all over here
so when we use find all it will actually
return us
each and every case where it found a b
or c
and uh you might not it won't tell you
the exact position
but it will tell you like um so if i
execute this you can see
it gives us a a list with a c
a and a and what this basically means is
it was looking for the characters a
or b or c and it found a first and hence
this
for the first item the list and then it
found a c and then it found two
is successfully so this is exact this is
actually how find all works
where it will actually find all of the
instances of our regex pattern
now that you've seen how the square
brackets work and how the
re.search and re dot match and re.find
all
methods work now we're going to go
through all the other meta characters
that we saw above
so the period now period matches any
single character
except the new line new line is
basically slash n or a break now if you
look at this
picture what it's going to do is um
this expression basically saying that uh
do we have
um two characters like sets of two
characters in our string
so this is a single character string and
obviously a single character string
is not a double character string and
this expression this double dot
is basically asking us do we have two
characters present in our string
so if i had to match it with this a it
will obviously be a no match because a
is one character
if we checked it with ac it is a match
because a and c are two characters
a c and d will also give us only one
match because it will find a c
and then it will leave d as a single
character but when we check a c
d and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because
it will consider a and c as one of the
matches and d and e as one of the
matches
so below is basically what we are doing
basically the same thing we're just
using rd dot search
for each of these different examples so
if i if you see when i use find all on
acde
and when i'm searching for a two
character match you will see that it
will return me a c
and d e as you can see here and
similarly for something like this it
will return me again
whatever like two character patterns it
finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier
then the carrick symbol is basically
used to check if a string
starts with a certain character so if
you look at these two
this picture if you have two two
expressions that we're going to check
over here
one is the uh one is checking if a is
the beginning of a string and
the other one will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first
string will be a match because it's only
the character a and it will match here
as well because this
string starts with a but it will not
match here because this string starts
with b
now if i look at this particular
expression
you can see that um this is going to
search for
if the string starts with a and is
followed by a b so it will match in this
case because a does start with a and is
followed by a b
but it will not match in this case even
though it starts with an a because it's
not followed by a b
so out here is basically us using the
ie.search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol
so the dollar symbol that you can see
here is used to check if a string ends
with a certain character and we've
already seen how this is used
in one of the uh one of the earlier
examples so this is going to check
basically if so this expression will
check if the string ends with a
so this this string is basically the
character a so it will match
this also ends with a so it will match
and this particular string
does not end with a so it will not match
and we are going to do that using the re
dot search
over here so as you can see it finds a
match
in the first character itself here in
this case it finds a match in the last
character
but in cab there is no match so it
returns us a none
another example is of the meta
characters
is star so this is the symbol for star
and
this what the star basically is used is
for
checking if there are zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it
so now if you see here what this will
check for is
um is there any form of m and a that
occurs before n and it's very important
to note that
the n has to follow the a in this case
so let's look at these examples and what
will happen
so if i checked it with m and n this is
actually a match because
n is followed by zero occurrences of m
and a
which is if it might seem a little weird
but it is technically the truth
because uh the the star symbol checks
for not
doesn't check for the existence it just
checks for if
n occurs it must occur after an
a or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the n
occurs after an m and it's fine because
there is no a
now you will see when it will not work
so m a and n is obviously fine
m a uh m triple a n is also fine because
n follows an a
and there's an m here this however main
will not match now why even though we
have m and a
and we have an n you see the n is
immediately followed by an
i is n follows an i immediately
or the n is preceded by an i immediately
and this is
a no match because our the strict
condition in the search is that n
must proceed in a if the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here
we're just going to use the id.search
for these examples that we
saw over here in terms of code using the
re.search
as you can see here finally we have the
next metacharacter
which is the plus symbol yes so the plus
symbol matches
one or more occurrences of the pattern
left to it
now this is very similar to what we saw
earlier in terms of the star
except now in the plus the key
difference is we're looking for one or
more occurrences
instead of zero or more occurrences that
we were looking for in the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now
we need what is there to the left of the
plus sign a zero
no occurrence of it will not be allowed
or will not cause a match
so let's see now what we're going to do
here we're going to use the same
expression except we're going to replace
the star with the plus sign
so now what we're going to say is okay
we need m and a at least one occurrence
followed by an n
the all of these conditions have to be
met so again if you took the first
example m and n
this time it will be a no match because
there is no occurrence of an a over here
for preceding the n so it's a no match m
a and n
is a match because well this is per this
is perfectly fine
m triple a and n is also perfectly fine
but if you look at m a i and n
much like earlier the n is preceded by
an i and not an a so there is no match
and again women is perfectly fine and we
basically execute the same thing through
the search function in this piece of
code the next meta character is the
question mark
the question mark symbol matches 0 or 1
occurrences of the pattern
to the left of it so let's see what this
does
so now we saw the star the star which
was 0 or more occurrences of the pattern
to the left of it
we saw the plus which is one or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it now we will see
the question mark which is zero or one
only zero
or only one and not zero or more of one
or more which was the
previous cases only zero and one or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it again we're going to see the same
expression except we're going to replace
the meta character with the question
mark
so now let's see what what happens when
we match so if you see here
m and n is a match because there is zero
occurrence of a
and one occurrence of m preceding n so
this is fine
this is also fine because there is one
way occurrence of a and m
and then it's preserved followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a which is
followed by an n
we're only looking for zero or one this
again main will be a no match for the
same reasons that we have already gone
through
and women will be a match again for the
same reasons
and we'll read through the same things
using the search function in this piece
of code
the next meta character is the braces
character now the braces character is
interesting because what we're going to
do
is we're going to see if there are so uh
this is
the typical syntax for the braces is and
a brace
followed by some integer n comma integer
m
and then closed braces so what this
means is we're looking for
at least n and at most m repetitions
of the pattern left of the braces let's
see through an example
if you see this expression we're looking
for at least
two and at most three occurrences of
this
the character a in our test strings so
let's see what happens in the first case
we have no matches in this case because
this part of the string contains only
one a
and even this part of the string only
contains one a we're looking for at
least two
and at most three this part will contain
one match the second the second example
because the second part of the string
actually contains
two a's for one uh two uh repetitions of
ace con
consecutively but this uh in the end and
in the third example
you can see both the strings actually
contain matches so we get two matches
because
as you can see here there's two a's here
followed by three a's here
now when we look at this particular
string let's look at what happens now
so what we're going to find is that this
thing is perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a
but now we have four occurrences of a
but what the
search engine is going to recognize is
these first three is and is going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and i already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a and the
search
it will just look at the first three and
say okay there are uh three a's and my
my match is fine so again there are two
matches in this case
again we're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case
now let's see the find all option and
see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred
in each of these lists now let's try to
use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say
different meta characters and we create
a a
more sophisticated expression that we
want to search in our test strings
so if you look at this expression what
we're looking for is
0-9 now a dash symbol is valid
in python using regex because what this
basically tells it
is that it's looking for either zero one
two three four
so on until nine basically any of the
digits you're
looking for any of the digits from zero
to nine and we're going to
uh check if at least two and at most
four
occurrences of digits if they are there
or not in our particular code
so let's see what are the matches that
happens when we use it on test strings
so if you use it on this string
you can see it'll find one match this
basically this particular part of the
string where it says one two three
so this is uh three occurrences of
digits so it's fine
now when we look at this whole string 12
and
whatever this is you will see this will
not find a match here this obviously
will not because these are characters
but if you look at over this part it
will find matches in the in terms of
the first four and then seven and three
the next two
one and two again there are no matches
because there's only single occurrences
of digits we're looking for it at
at least two and at most four so if i
use the find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first
test string what is going to return me
is it's going to return me one two and
three as you can see here
but now if you look at this test string
it's going to return me
12 it's going to return me 3 4 5 and 6
is going to return me 3 4 1 and 2 but
not 7 because we're looking for at least
2
and then it's going to return me 4 5 6
and 7 followed by 8
and 8 as you can see in this list over
here now if we use curly braces with
only one digit
it's basically telling the search engine
that uh we want
exactly so many repetitions of the
preceding uh
whatever kind of expression that we have
so
when we do this example for uh for
example we're basically
saying that we want uh x
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times
in our particular expression and then it
should be followed by an x again
which will not match in this case
because there are only two dashes and it
will match in this case because there
are exactly three dashes
and it will again not not match in this
case because there are four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object match followed by none
next we move on to the alternation um
the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of a and b
so a should be followed by a b and uh
basically this pattern has to keep going
on so in the first string over here this
pattern will not match
in the second string over here uh we
will have a match because we at least
find an a even though there is no b
but this is to consider match because we
did find an a at least
over here we'll have uh three matches
because we have a followed by a b
followed by an a again so if we did a
reg expression for this
we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis
is basically used to group sub patterns
so let's look at an example to
understand what we mean
now if you look at this complicated
expression what this means
is that i want some form of x and z
the x and z have to occur together but
before that
what i want is some form of a following
b
following c some sort of alternation
between a b and c
so this part as you can see here is kept
in a parenthesis because i want this
whole condition
to basically occur before i find in x
and z
so let's look at what happens here in
the first case we don't have a match
because
uh there this basically this parenthesis
condition is not being met
the x and z is preceded by a space or
basically the a and b is preceded
is followed by a space so if the space
didn't occur we would actually find a
match
as you can see in the next example here
you can see a and b occur
basically this uh initial condition is
met followed by x and z so there is
a one match so it's fine for us now if
you look at this
slightly more a trickier one what you
can see
is we have two matches in this case
first in a followed by x and z
and then we have c a and b now
this is perfectly fine because we we are
looking for a b
followed by an x and z we're looking for
either of these things
we're looking for some form of
alternation of these things followed by
an x and z
and we can get that over here we get b
followed by an x and z
so you'll get two matches in this case
now let's go through the concept of
grouping constructs now that you've seen
many meta characters you've seen how
parenthesis works
let's look at grouping constructs so
grouping constructs break up a regex in
python into
sub expressions or groups and this
serves two purposes one is a grouping
part which basically says that a group
represents a single syntactic entity
and any additional meta characters apply
to the entire group as a unit
and then there's a capturing part which
basically tells us that some grouping
constructs also capture the portion of
the search string that matches the sub
expression in the group
you can retrieve captured matches later
through several different mechanisms
so let's look at basically what we mean
by this example over here
so if you see this this expression has a
plus sign
so we're looking for a as you know a
plus looks for one or more occurrence
so this will basically check for one or
more occurrence of the
character r only because there's no
parenthesis as in this example
so this plus is next to an r and it's
going to
check for basically whether one or more
occurrence of r
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put
b a and r in a parent thesis followed by
plus it will actually check for the
entire string bar
and it will check one or more
occurrences of bar together
so if you look at these two examples
when we use this
uh on these examples you can see that
these are fine like these matches are
fine
but if i used this parenthesis
then these would be the acceptable
matches and like ba triple r would not
be a match if i use parenthesis
uh as you can see here so this is how
grouping constructs work
and how parenthesis work so let's look
at some other examples
so what this will do is f-o-o has to be
optionally followed by b-a-r
and b-a-r must exist together and
this is because we have a question mark
here this question mark symbol tells us
that there should be zero or one
occurrences
similarly this particular complicated
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences of whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing is followed
by a plus so we're looking for this
whole sequence
for one or more occurrences of it c o w
is simply just c o w we're looking for
this pattern
and this is going to check for
zero or one occurrence of c or w because
of the existence of the question mark
for
preceded by the parenthesis in this
video we are going to continue our
discussion on regular expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
expressions
let's continue our discussion with
special sequences
now in an earlier video on strings you
might have encountered
what is an escape sequence and how we
use the backslash character to generate
these escape sequences
and an escape sequence is basically if
you remember
something that we use to either gives a
certain special meaning to characters
that are otherwise
ordinary or it is used to remove the
special meaning that are inherently
present in certain characters
that we call meta characters so let's
look at what special sequences are
in relation to regular expressions so
the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital a which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present
are present at the start of a string so
out here if you can see
we are checking if the word d
is present in these two strings so we
would get a match in the first case over
here because this starts with the word d
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it
for the same thing using the find all
function so if you see
in the first case it gives us it returns
us an object
because we do find d in the beginning of
the string in the second case we
get us empties list because the string
does not start with the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash b
small b now this is used to match if
specified characters at the beginning or
at the end of a word
so when you use backslash small b and
then you follow it up with whatever
you're looking for
it would look for the that particular
those particular characters or that
pattern
if it exists in the beginning of a word
in a string
so if you look at the first example it
starts with f double o
and in the second example you see this
portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double o so it will also
match
however in this string which is very
similar to the second one
we don't have a space between a and f
and it's basically one word so this does
not start with f double o but it
actually starts with afo
and it won't match as you can see here
now similarly if we wanted to check if
something exists in the back of a string
at the end of a string we type what we
want to search for first
and then we follow it with a backslash
small b and
then if you see here it will match in
this first case it will
match in the second case because this
part of the string ends with f double o
but it will not match in this case
because well we remove the space so now
this whole thing becomes a
the string that we're looking for and it
does not end with fw anymore
and this is basically us just checking
it through the find all function
now the next sk the next special
sequence that we will be looking at
is the slash capital b which is
basically the opposite of what we just
saw
this matches only if the specified
characters are not at the beginning or
the end of a word
so if you see here this is checking if f
double o is not at the beginning
of these strings so in this case there
will be a no match
in this case also it will be a no match
in this third case there will be a match
similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with
a particular string we would type that
whatever pattern we are looking for
followed by a backslash capital b and
then we can use the find all function to
generate us lists wherever we find such
objects find such matches in our
particular test strings
like we have done over here so the next
one that we're going to look at is the
backslash small d
and this matches any decimal digit which
is equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9 as you seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and if we did a search or a find all
or a match
it would look for any of the digits
between 0 and 9.
so a similar thing can be done using a
special sequence backslash small d
so as you can see there will be three
matches in this case because one two and
three digits exist
whereas in this case for the word python
there will be no matches
so these are certain examples where
we're doing the same thing using the
backslash d
now we have another one which is the
backslash capital d and this is just
basically the opposite
it matches for any non-decimal digits
it's also equivalent to typing
a carrot inside square brackets with 0-9
which if you remember from the previous
video is basically
asking us to check for anything that is
not
the digit 0 to 9. so
this is basically we're going to check
in these two strings if there is no
digits and no
non-decimal digits so if you see here we
will
find three matches a b and the uh double
double inverted
commas and in the second string we will
find no matches because
this is fully just digits next we have
backslash small s
now this matches where a string contains
any white space character
so this is equal to doing a check for
all of these
so this is like backslash small t is a
check for tab space backslash small
n is a check for break line and then
backslash r
black slash f backslash b uh are are
their own
uh checks for uh different sorts of
white space characters
that you can see by just looking it up
honestly but yeah so if you simply do a
backslash
s it would actually be the equivalent of
searching for any of these
white space white space characters that
we generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string
you can see that there is one space over
here so it will match
it will give us one match because there
is one white space which is just the
normal space here
and in the second example there is no
match because there is no white space
here
similarly slash capital s now as you
might have noticed
is basically checking for a string which
does not matches in a string wherever
there is no white space characters
so it's basically the same as doing
carrot slash t slash n slash
r f slash v in a square brackets so this
is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
in a carrot symbol so if you
see this expression backslash capital s
now we're looking at uh
a space b so over here if you see it
will match for all the non spaces
so it's going to match for a and b so
we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty spring
is basically a white space character on
its own so this would be this will give
us a no match
so the next special sequence that we're
gonna look at is the backslash small w
uh this matches any alphanumeric
character which is the equivalent of
doing a to z
in small and then capital a to z and
zero to nine
follow and also an underscore check in
square brackets
um it's also it's important to note that
the underscore is considered an alpha
minimic character hence why we include
it over here
but yeah this is this uh backslash w uh
small w which basically checks for
any alpha numeric character and matches
it in a string
so if you see in this first case it will
find three matches
at one two and also at the letter c
these others are not alphanumeric
characters whereas in this string none
of these are alphanumeric characters so
we will get no match
again much like the other examples there
is a capital there's a backslash capital
w which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character
and it's the equivalent of doing
whatever we did before in uh
in the square brackets just with a
preceded by a carrot sign so if you see
here
we have this string where we have a
bunch of characters
well yeah only one of them this uh
percentage symbol is a non-alphanumeric
character so we will get my one match
over here
but in this case in the string python we
will get no matches because they are all
alphanumeric characters which is doing
the same thing here with a bunch of
different examples using the find all
function
now the backslash capital z matches if
the specified characters are at the end
of a string
now don't confuse this with uh backslash
small b plus the backslash small b
checks for a string and it checks each
and every word in the string
individually and checks if so if any of
the words
ends with a particular thing or or
starts with a particular thing but it
checks each word individually
but in this case the backslash capital z
will check the string only and not each
word
so if you see the difference here in an
um when you use capital backslash
capital z
um it will match in this first example
but it won't match for the next two
but if you used a backslash small b over
here
it would actually match not only in the
first example here but it will also
match
in the second example because it would
check this word individually and it will
find out that yeah there is a match here
as well
so it would actually match in the second
example as well in this video we will be
covering the topic of serialization in
python now object serialization
is very simply put when we want to
convert a
data structure or an object type
and we want to translate this into a
form that is
that can be stored in in in a memory
such as
a a file or a memory buffer
later we could deserialize this
particular file
and reconstruct the original object out
of it now in python
this is done object serialization is
done by converting the state of any
object
into a byte string this byte stream can
be further stored in any file like
objects such as a disk file or memory
stream
it can also be transmitted via sockets
deserialization as i mentioned earlier
is the process of reconstructing the
object from the byte stream
now in python we refer to the
serialization and deserialization by the
terms pickling and unpickling
so the pickle module which is which is a
model that is a part of the standard
library of python
um it provides functions for
serialization such as the dump and the
dumps function
and also for d serialization with load
and loads
the data format of pixel module is
specific to is very python specific and
so
programs that are not written in python
may not be able to deserialize the
pickle data properly and it's also
considered
unsecured to unpickle data from uh
unauthenticated sources so in this
example here what i'm going to do
is um i'm going to the i'm going to take
the dictionary object
which is represented by dct and its byte
representation will be stored in a file
called pickled.txt
and uh we will also gonna enable the
write and binary mode preemptively so if
you can see here first i'm importing the
pickle package and then i'm opening
my file pickle.txt and write in binary
mode
then i create this dictionary and i'm
going to dump this dictionary into
that particular file and then i'm going
to basically close the file
so this uh executing this would do this
now it's important to note apical file
cannot is not a human
uh readable file a computer can
understand this but it's
some so the byte representation of any
object or data type
cannot be read by a human
in plain sight so this next part is
where where i'm going to deserialize or
i'm going to unpickle
the file.txt so again i'm importing
pickle
i'm opening opening this file in read in
binary mode
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
load this into d
this will basically in a way deserialize
whatever was there in pickle.txt
and once i have unloaded it in d i'm
going to print what's the content of the
which should be my original dictionary
itself
so when i execute this you can see that
printing defense my original dictionary
that we had before
and it's important to note since
dictionaries are unordered
so dictionary objects don't retain the
order of insertion of keys so in the way
so the way we enter the keys inside the
dictionary
when we create it is not maybe the same
way that we will see the
the order of the key the key value pairs
when we actually unload it
now there exists a dumps function inside
the pickle module
that pickles python data to a string
representation so we're going to do that
in this
next piece of code so i'm importing the
dumps function from
the pickle module and i have my same
dictionary what i'm going to do is i'm
going to dump this dictionary into dct
string
and i'm going to print tct string to
show you like what exactly
a string representation of this
dictionary would typically look like
so when you execute this you see this
something very cryptic so this is
basically
what we mean by the string
representation um of course we can use
the loads function again to unpick
whatever we just did and get the
original dictionary representation of
this particular string so that's what
we're doing in this piece of code
and as you can see we get back our
dictionary over here
so now in our second example what we're
going to do is
we're going to create slightly more
complex data structures and we are going
to
do some uh serialization deserialization
on them
so we have this function called
storedata where uh
we initialize two dictionaries called
omkar and jagdish with some certain key
value pairs
um now we create another uh another
dictionary empty dictionary called db
which will be like our database and now
this db has uh
two keys again called omkar and jagdish
once again
and now if you notice my keys my new
keys are omkar and jagdish
but their values are these new
dictionaries again
so um we're basically storing a
dictionary within
a dictionary so as to speak so once we
have done that
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a another
file called example pickle and we're
going to
create it in binary mode now once we've
done that we're going to dump this this
dictionary db into this this file called
uh
db file where we have uh opened
basically where we're going to store uh
the serialized representation of this
dictionary called db and then we're
going to close so this is what store
data will do when we call this function
and in load data what we're going to do
is we're going to print out
um what each key and what uh what it
represents
so we're going to basically deserialize
in the load data function we're going to
deserialize whatever we
just serialized in the previous function
so when we execute this
we should basically get something like
ohm card followed by
this sort of an arrow sign and whatever
the dictionary that we have assigned to
omcart is
similarly for jagdish as well so when we
do store data it will basically do the
serialization process
um and when we do load data it should do
the deserialization and print out the
original the db dictionary that we
created in store data over here
so let's execute these two
oops i did not execute the load data so
now it should work
yeah so if you see now when i when i
have executed load data
i get back um so basically from store
data i first
serialized my whole file into a
particular file called db file
and once i have done that i have
deserialized it using the load data
function over here
in this video we will be covering the
topic of python partial functions
now partial functions allow us to fix a
certain number of arguments
for a function and generate a new
function the func tools.partial module
helps us achieve this now let's say we
want to create a function that
explicitly performs exponentiation
so we can get squares cubes and other
power operations on any number
so let's look at an example so we create
this function called power
where we have a base and an exponent so
what this does it will basically print
some number which is the base to the
power of some exponent
and the result which will be returned
over here so
let's define let's see now what if we
want to create
a dedicated square in cube functions
that leverages this
so we can define a square um function
called
with an argument called base where we
return the power
of the same base to the power of two so
basically we're doing for we're defining
a square function
with the help of this function that we
defined already called power
um for cube we will basically do the
same power function but the exponent
will be 3.
so now when we do square 10 we're going
to say if we executed all of this
so now if we say square 10 what this
will do is it would say 10 to the power
of 2
is 100 and if you see the next one cube
5 5 to the power 3 should be 125 as you
can see here
now this works but what if we want to
create say 15 to 20 variations of
our power functions and what about say
one thousands of them
writing uh defining a function for each
case is obviously very repetitive it's
annoying
and this is where we will find partials
coming into play
so as an example let's do the same thing
now what we're going to do is we're
going to import partial from the module
called func tools
we have a what we're going to define is
this function called square
which is basically going to use the
partial functions
operation for the power function with
the exponent of two
so what we're doing is basically we're
going to use the power we're going to
reference the power function that we
defined earlier but we're going to pass
the uh
the argument for exponent s2 and for
cube we're going to do the same thing
but exponent is 3.
so once you've defined this if you do
square 2 you get the result as you can
see
for cube 2 you get the result as you can
see here let's look at another example
so we have this function where we
defined some function with
four arguments now what we're going to
do is
argument a b c and x right so we're
going to return thousand times a
100 times plus 100 times b plus 10 times
c plus x
now we're going to create a partial
function that calls this function
but it's going to use um a as 3 b as 1
and cs4 always right and
so that how we do that is basically g is
equal to partial like this
so once we've executed these now if we
say g10
we basically get the value for a
thousand times
well thousand times three since a is
three plus hundred times
b as one so hundred times one plus ten
times well c is four so ten times
4 plus x now x we passed is 10 so the
result of all this will be
33 31 50 as you can see here
now let's look at a final example where
i've defined some function called add i
have three arguments a b and c what i
returned from the sat function
is 100 times a plus 10 times b plus c
so let's create a partial for using
partial functions where b
and b is 1 and c is 2. so we have this
fixed we can create a partial function
called add part
so what this does is it takes the add
function it creates a partial function
out of it using c is equal to 2 and b is
equal to 1.
so now when i print add part 3 what
happens here is
3 gets passed in the form of a so i get
3 3 times 100
and since b is fixed as 1 and c is 2 so
i get 3 times 100 plus
1 times 10 plus 2 so it should give me
312 so when i execute this
you can see this here in this video we
will be covering the topic of closures
now before we understand what a closure
is we have to understand what is a
nested function and non-local variables
now a function which is inside another
function is known as a nested function
nested functions are able to access
variables of the enclosing scope
so if i define this function called
outer function where i pass
some argument called text and i store
that in a variable called text again
and if i create a function within this
call in a function and i want to print
whatever this variable is in text
when i execute this it will be able to
access this variable because
it's within the enclosing scope so if i
set outer function hey
this gets stored in the variable text
and then the inner function will print
that variable which is basically the
string here as you can see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body
so here our inner function is treated as
a nested function which uses
text this this variable text as the
non-local variable
now a closure is a function object that
remembers values
in enclosing scopes even if they are not
present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment
it's a mapping basically that associates
each free variable of the function
which are basically variables that are
used locally
but are defined in enclosing scope with
the value or reference to which the name
was bound when the closure was created
a closure which is uh which unlike a
plane function
allows the function to access those
captured variables through the closures
copies of their values or references
even when the function is invoked
outside the scope so let's look at an
example to
emphasize on what what was just said so
again i've created i've defined this
function out a function where i'm doing
the same thing
now i've defined the same inner function
where i'm going to print the same thing
now it's very important that when i
return over here
what i'm going to return is inner
function but it's not going to be a
function call
this is important to create our closure
so we return in our function but with
without
um using the call as we do over here
and what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure
sorry the closure where the inner
function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now i'm going to store this outer
function in an object called my
in a variable called my function now
when i call this my function
um you can see there there'll be two
things that are happening here
so once i've defined this and i've
executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed
and then i'm storing it to this but
because i've done return inner function
without parent thesis i have created a
closure basically
and this closure allows the inner
function
to remember the values that were stored
in text at any point
and at every point even after the
execution of this one time
so when i execute this again for the
second time over here it will remember
the value that was stored in the
variable text which is
hey which was which was given over here
that's why you see when i execute it for
the second time over here
the first time being in this line when
i'm storing it in my function
when i execute in the second time again
it would give me the result
of hey as you can see the closures have
to invoke functions outside the scope
the function in a function has a scope
only inside the outer function but with
the user closures
we can extend its scope to invoke a
function outside the
scope so now let's look at this code so
this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we defined
called add
x and y which will return x plus y and
the subtract function which will
subtract x and y so now we're going to
execute these
once we're going to execute the add over
here and add logger
and we're going to execute the subtract
function and we're going to store it in
sublogger
so technically we have already executed
these two functions
but now uh since i've created an x
an enclosure basically uh if you see
here this is the enclosure that i have
created
now what happens is when i
access this function from outside its
initial scope which is basically over
here this was the initial scope
when i access it outside you will see
that it is
it still has access to these variables x
and y so if you see here i
i first of all i've allowed this uh this
the enclosing function to accept uh
arguments of any numbers
so uh i can pass xy i can pass xyz also
but if you see here i only have thing
for x and y
so when i want to access any value of x
and y
even after the execution of this code
initially um i have access to these
variables x and y
and that is because i've created a
closure out of that
so if you see if i do add logger 3 and 3
over here
i'm able to get the result 6. if i do
add logger 4 and 5 i'm able to get the
result 9.
similarly for subtraction logger 10 and
5 i will get 5 here and 20 and 10 i'll
get 10 here
and uh i can keep doing this i can keep
saying add logger in fact if i say 4
and 7 so if i executed this and now i'm
going to say
let's say for example add logger if i
set 4
and 7 here so this still has access to
my variables x and y because i've
created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if i
did sub logger say 30 and 15
it should give me 15 because 30 minus 15
so let's say 30 minus 16 right so it
should give me 14 because again
i have created the closure and it has
access to these variables already
in this video we are going to be
learning about the topic of decorators
to start off with let's first understand
some basic concepts
now in python we know that functions are
first class objects and that means
that functions are objects and they can
be referenced to and they can be passed
to a variable and they can be returned
from other functions as well
functions can also be defined another
function and can be passed as an
argument to other functions
so decorators allow programmers to
modify the behavior of a function or
class
decorators allow us to wrap another
function in order to
extend the behavior of the wrap function
without permanently modifying it
now any generic functionality that you
can tack on to an existing
class or functions behavior makes a
great use case for decoration
some of these include rate limiting
caching logging
enforcing access control and authentic
authentication
instrumentation and timing functions now
you have to remember
that function names are references to
functions and that we can assign
multiple names to the same function
so for example if you see here
i have defined a function called success
which does basically you pass an integer
and it returns
one plus side integer so if i do success
10 it should give me 11
as you can see here now if i'm if i'm
gonna say successor is equal to success
i've basically created another function
called successor
which does the same job as a success
function so now if i
pass 20 to successor it should return 21
as you can see here so as you can see
that we have two names
success and successor for the same
function
an important fact is that we can delete
either one of the
any of the functions and you won't
delete the other one
so if i said delete success and if i
tried to pass 10 to the other function
called successor
it would still execute the whatever task
the function is supposed to do now let's
look at an example
of a function inside a function so i've
defined a function called
f in which i have defined another
function called g which has two print
statements that you can see here
the function f itself has two print
statements
and in at the end of the execution of
function f
we call this function g so let's see
what happens when we actually execute
f so let's uh look at it on this side
so if you see here this is where i've
defined it now let's call
my function f and let's see what happens
as you can see
first when you execute function f it
will create this function
and then it will print these functions
and then it will do a call to this
and when we call this function g it's
going to do two of its own print
statements as you can see in this order
over here so this is an example of a
function within another function
let's look at another example of
something similar if you see here i've
defined a function called temperature
where i can pass
some value for t and have a i have
defined another function within this
called celsius to fahrenheit and
basically i'm doing the conversion
so when i execute this what it should
return me is
i'll pass some temperature and it and it
will return me the temperature in
degrees
so for example in this case i pass
temperature 20
so let's see what uh does it pass what
result does it give to me in degrees
as you can see it says it's 68 degrees
now let's look at another example of a
function within a function for a very
common example for the factorial
function
so if you see here i've defined
factorial n
and i'm saying if the value that is
passed in n is equal to 0
return me 1 otherwise return me the
product of that number
times and i'm going to do a recursive
call back to the same function
except now i'm not going to pass n but n
minus 1 so what this should do is if i
pass 10 for example
it will basically check okay since 10 is
not equal to 0 it will go here
and it will return me 10 times factorial
of
9 and that will do 10 times 9 times
8 and then so on until we reach uh n
is equal to zero where it will just say
okay return one so what you will
effectively get is ten times
nine times eight times seven so on until
one which is basic
factorial of whatever we have passed so
let's execute this
see i'm going to check what is the
factorial 5 here and as you can see it
gives me 120.
now let's have a let's include a line uh
and it says an exception
by an else statement which will
basically raise a type error
and it will tell me that if i pass a
number
n which is not an int and if it's not
greater than or equal to 0 it should
give me this
error message so i have included this
extra statement in this
just to check so if i pass nine as you
can see it should give me
a valid result which is three six two
eight eight zero
now what if i passed minus five so let's
execute this
as you can see i get the uh the type
error that i have raised over here
in case i made such a condition and in
this case you cannot find the factorial
of a negative integer so that is why my
type error gets raised over here
if you actually look closely at this
program you will notice that
each time i call back my function
factorial
so if i gave it five initially it will
check for the
this this condition and since it's it
will meet the condition
we can continue but the next time when
we call factorial for four
and then for three and two each time is
going to do this check
that's kind of redundant because we know
that if we passed five in the beginning
uh until we decrement it to zero we're
going to only get the
valid numbers five four three two and
one so we don't need to do this check at
every point we just need to do one check
so and a workaround for this
would be in this code that i'm i've
written over here
and in this i've basically defined a
factorial function called n
which will where i'll pass my integer
initially
and within that i've defined the actual
function where the actual
results will be calculated and that's
called inner factorial this is where the
um this is basically the actual
factorial calculating part
and if you see this if statement block
this is my check
so this will basically be the only check
that will happen
so out here it will check whether the n
i have passed is a valid integer and
equal to or greater than zero and if it
is
then we will perform this inner
factorial function where
we won't be doing any more suspects we
will only calculate the
factorial and if it's not then we will
raise
this exception just once and we will
exit the program in case we've given a
wrong number
so let's look at an example for three so
as you can see at each step of my
calculations i'm going to
return whatever value i have at that
point
so basically if i give 3
you'll notice that you will get 0 1 2
and 6 if you multiply it in the right
way
so let's do this as you can see
factorial 3
one second so i have to execute this now
if i execute this
you can see i first get because
initially it will check
when i move into inner factorial check
if n is equal to equal to zero
it will basically return whatever value
i have at that point so basically this
is the
uh order of calculations in number in a
backward way so
you can see here it will first be 1
and then 1 times 2 and then 2 times 3
which is 6 which is what we get so
don't worry about the order in which we
are returning these values this is
basically just
a reverse way in which the the program
will fetch our values
so yeah this was basically how we reduce
the redundancy
in in the check in the check part of our
function
now let's look at some examples where a
function will be returning
another function so as we know the
output of a function is also a reference
to an object and therefore functions can
return references to function objects
so out here if you see i've defined a
function called f which will take a
parameter called x and then within it
i've defined a function called g
which will have a parameter called y and
this g will basically return y
plus x plus 3 and the function f itself
will return
the function g so if i pass 10 in
function so what this will do is it will
create a function called g
and you create an instance of a function
called g and that object is going to be
returned to us because we basically
return g
when we call function x right so if i
execute this
you will see that when i say f10 it will
give me some
object location of a function called g
now if i want to see the result
of what i get for this function g i have
to pass something within g
itself so out here what i'm going to do
is i'm going to store this function
object in a variable called
nf1 once i've done that i can pass
another
parameter for this nf1 object uh and
since we know this nf1 is a variable
name for the function g
so when i pass nf 120 i'm basically
passing this y parameter
so since now i have passed 10 for x and
i have passed 20 for y
oops one second yeah so what i will get
returned is 20 plus 10 plus 3 which is
33
when i do nf1 and i pass 20 as the
parameter here
as you can see i get 33 over here now
let's uh look at
a function where we will implement
polynomials of degree two
and then we will actually extend that to
polymer polynomials of any degree
so i have created a function called
polynomial creator
where i pass three arguments which will
represent the coefficients
so a will represent the x square
coefficient b will represent the x
coefficient and see the constant
so i have defined within this i've
defined a polynomial function called x
where i will pass my value for the
variable x and i want to get
returned the um the value for this
polynomial
so as you can see here initially when i
the first function will return this
object and then for this object itself i
will have to pass
another argument where i'll pass the
value of x
so let's create so i'm going to create
two instances of this polynomial
function
in and in the first instance my
coefficients are as you can see 2 3 and
minus 1.
in the second case will be minus 1 2 and
1. so once i execute this
oops let me execute the function
initially yeah there you go
so if you if i if i execute p1 it will
basically give me a
object location of the polynomial
function for p1
which is represented by this basically
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to iterate through
values between minus 2 and 2 not
including 2
at steps of 1 so i'm going to iterate
for minus 2 minus 1 0 and 1
and i'm going to say initially print me
the values of x that i'm
going to pass in this column this first
column and then i'm going to say okay
what are the results for the first
polynomial object where the coefficients
are 2 3 and minus 1
and then in this column give me the
values of the polynomial with these
coefficients minus 1 2 and 1.
so when i execute this as you can see
these are my results
now what if i wanted to do the same
thing for arbitrary coefficients
as in a polynomial of nth degree you
know i'm not specifying the exact degree
so this i can do with this slightly
slightly more complicated
program which is actually very very
simple
so if you see this function i've defined
a polynomial created function again
but in this case i have passed variable
number of arguments so this
asterisk basically means i can have any
number of arguments here
um and this will be an iterable with uh
any n number of um objects that can be
iterated upon
so and that will be called coefficients
so within that again i've defined
polynomial x
now what i've done is i've initialized
some variable called res which is
basically be my result variable
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
for loop through
this coefficients interval and what this
basically does
is in a backward way um this is
basically going to
iterate through the uh the array or the
list or whatever we have
of coefficients in a backward way so if
i pass
6 7 8 9 is going to give me
9876 in that order and what this
enumerate function will do is
um it will assign an index to each of
the values and coefficients
so for example i can just show you over
here what this means so if i created a
array called um say
coefficients with some some random
values over here
right now if i'm going to perform this
line
right now let's see what happens when we
do a for loop let's see what values we
get for index
and when we do this execute this line
so if you see here now once i execute
this as you can see
what i have done is coefficients
oh i made a smelly mistake this is
taking from a different
variable so let's fix this so as you can
see
i've entered four objects uh four
integers one twenty three four and forty
five
and um when i do this for loop i
basically want to assign some index
value zero one two and three
to each value in this list but in a
backwards manner so this will be the
zeroth item
this will be the first this will be the
second this will be the third
so that's what we are doing in this
function as well out here
we are basically uh going to use this
enumerate function
to now if you see this this result is
basically going to add each
each component of this polynomial so if
you see closely what this is going to do
is it's going to first
in the first step is going to find out
well
what is the value of this the constant
term and then in the next step is going
to
find out what is the value of this and
it's going to keep summing it up it's
going to sum this part up this part up
until the end and then we will get our
final result
in this variable res and we're going to
return that over here
so if you see here i when i've done the
same thing i've created four function
objects
and they're called p one p two p three p
four and now i'm going to iterate
through again minus two minus one zero
and one um as my different x values and
i'm going to see what are the different
values for each of these polynomials
so if you see here my first polynomial
is basically uh
it has only one coefficient so it's a
polynomial of the zeroth degree
so basically whatever i pass for x that
itself should
uh be my result so actually this is the
polynomial
degree so this is basically the only
result you will get so
the constant is four you will get four
in every result so if you see here what
i'm printing is the x values first
and what are their respective polynomial
values for each
of these objects that we've created so
this is a constant so p1 will only have
the result four
this is p2 so this is a polynomial
degree one so it's like saying two x
plus four and where x takes values minus
two minus one zero and one
and in this case you can see this is a
polynomial of fourth degree so it's like
saying
x to the power 4 plus 8x cubed minus
x squared plus 3x plus 2. so
the when we replace x with minus 2 minus
1 0 and 1
we get the respective values in the p3
column over here
and for p4 it's a it's a it's basically
a square polynomial
so yeah this is an example of how we can
create
a we can do a polynomial creator and get
our results accordingly
now interestingly enough what we've done
here is basically like for example let's
look at p3
right p3 is basically this polynomial
now this polynomial function inside our
decorator
uh polynomial creator so all these
examples that i've been showing you
where functions are within functions
um if you think of it it's it's like i'm
giving some basic function x
extra or like i'm doing something extra
within them right
so we can use decorators for this and
in our example over here what i can do
with this
function is i can implement the same
operation more
efficiently by using a decorator within
our main function so we can factorize it
in a way that it does not need any
exponentiation
so we can if you if you think of it this
polynomial
can be represented like this right if
you think of it
it's basically this times x plus some
constant
and then that whole thing is again times
x plus some constant
since this is a to the power 4 um this
is all we need
but if you think of it if we keep going
further all you have to do is again
enclose it in another bracket and then
do times x so we can basically
use a decorator to do this so if you
look at this function over here what
i've done is
i've created the same polynomial creator
with a variable number of arguments
but in this inside this function like um
what i've done in the form of a
decorator is that i'm going to
implement this polynomial in by
calculating the result in this manner
where um it's going to be very much more
efficient and you don't have to keep
exponentiating like how i did in this
example
so that's what i'm doing over here and
if you see um that is basically
implemented over here through this
so when i do the same when i execute the
same thing
and if i go through the for loop again
it should give me the same results but
it's it's much more efficient
now let's look at another example of a
simple decorator so we have a
i've defined a function called our
decorator fung
now this will basically be this this is
a reference to another function itself
if you see
within this but inside my decorator i
have a function wrapper
where i'm going to print this statement
before actually
like calling the function x before
calling the function
and i'm going to perform a print
statement again after that and i'm going
to return the function wrapper at the
end of
like executing the decorator so
let's look at what happens when we
define this function
for x so this is basically a simple
print statement where i'm saying
hi four has been called with um whatever
this is
um argument so
now let's execute what happens when i
say foo hi so as you can see
um let's execute the whole thing so yeah
as you can see here
i have executed this it says this is the
print statement that i've basically
written over here
and this is basically this is what gets
printed when i call this function here
now when i move on to the next statement
uh middle
what i'm declaring is i'm going to now
decorate foo with f
now what this means is i've now created
this uh of this decorator object
basically so let's let's look at what
happens when i execute this and then
i'll try to explain to you
so when i execute the whole thing you
can see something else is happening now
so we have we call foo after decoration
then we have this before calling
foo and uh this is basically this print
function this is the print function that
actually gets executed here
now we have this this is the function
call this is basically the function call
um which is this which is basically this
for function
and this is this line is being printed
from this
so if you see here i'm i'm getting some
results from this
like from this decorator itself but i'm
also
calling upon the function that is being
referred to by this decorator so
i'm doing two things i'm doing the main
thing which is being executed here which
is the result is here
but i'm also decorating it with these
two lines which comes from this
decorator called our decorator
so let's look at the explanation so if
you look at the output of this previous
program
we can see what's going on and that is
that the decoration for
this when we did this line which was
over here
it's a reference to the function wrapper
which is this now in this function
wrapper
this function itself right like this
function that we defined here
that will be called as well but we will
also
have a bunch of extra like print
statements in the form of these two
lines
which you can see over here before
calling and after calling that we have
also done along with this
so this is a simple example of how we've
used a decorator to
modify our basic function now this usual
syntax for decorators in python is
with the at the at symbol so we can
write the same thing like what we did
before
through this so we write at our
decorator and this will basically
apply the decorator to this function for
x so when we do at
our decorator and then we define this
function and we call it
it will basically do the the same thing
as um
doing this for example so
if i execute this you can see the same
thing has happened here
now i'm going to give you another
example of a decorator remember the
factorial function that we did earlier
where we did a check within the
factorial function but let's see how we
can use decorators to
add our case in this so as we as we know
before we calculate the factorial of
something we want to make sure that
whatever we pass is greater than or
equal to zero and it's an integer right
so let's define a decorator which will
basically do this
so this in this decorator what we're
going to do is we're going to call it a
create a function called a helper where
we're going to perform this check
and this is going to be our decorator
basically right
however so what this this will do what
this will do is basically this decorator
will say okay
if this check is met then you can
perform you can return the value of
function of x which is
the function is what is what we pass in
this
as an argument to the decorator so
once the check is done we can perform a
factorial so
that's what we're going to do here so
we've defined our decorator
now we're going to use the decorator
here and we're going to define within it
a factorial function so when we actually
perform the factorial like for some
numbers
like we're going to do factorial of one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
all these uh ten digits from one to nine
sorry
so if you're going to do that what it's
going to do is at each step
um so for the value one it's going to
first check
whether our integer passed is actually
the correct form of an integer
whether it's in integer and greater than
equal to zero so once that is done then
it will move on to the factor actual
factorial function
so when we do for i in range one and ten
since every number is valid we won't get
a
like we won't nothing nothing wrong will
happen there won't be any exception
raised
but what if we did factorial minus 1 now
now the factorial function itself
doesn't have a check but since we have a
decorator around this
factorial function it's first going to
do this check
and if it finds an error it will raise
an exception so if i do this
if you see when my exit when i execute
it raises my exception
so this is how we have added some
functionality to the original factorial
function using this decorator
in this video we will be covering the
topics of map filter and reduce
functions
in python now python provides several
functions that enable functional
approach to programming
and since functional programming is all
about expressions
some of these expression oriented
functions of python are
lambda functions list comprehensions map
filter
map filter and reduce now we've already
covered the topic of lambda and list
comprehensions
now let's cover the topics of map filter
and reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes
a function and a sequence a function is
basically
some defined some user defined function
or any function
a sequence is basically an iterable
object like a list or
a tuple for example or a bunch of lists
and tuples as well
so let's look at an example so one of
the most common operations that we do
with something like a list is
doing an operation on each of the
elements in the list and then
outputting a new list with the
the values as whatever we have modified
to the original items
of the uh list so we do what if we did
the square of all of these items in this
list
and we we want to create a list based on
that so we can basically iterate through
it and we can do a square function
and then append those values to a new
list called squared
and when we do this for example
over here you can see when we print
squared
we should get the list of whatever
square values we have
for the original list but this is uh
slightly a bit tedious and what if we
had
a method that or a what if we had
a technique wherein we could
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this
and we pass it to a function and this
function basically takes care of
applying whatever operations we want to
do on each element of a sequence
so as this is where the map function
comes in use so let's look at
how we use the map function over here so
if you look at this
i've defined a square function so the
square function basically returns uh
takes an argument x and it returns the
square of it
and i have a map function which takes
the square
function as one of the arguments and uh
the i
the list or an iterable as the second
argument so this map function creates a
map object
if you see here so let's just do it one
by one so i'm creating my list
and i'm going to create my function
called square
and i'm going to send this to the map
function
so i'm sending this the first argument
as the function that i want to do
and the second argument as the list that
i want to apply it on
now let's list out all the items that
are in this map object
if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed
and another way of doing the same thing
would be just going through a for loop
in each
of the map objects and printing each
which would give me the same results
so if you see here i found a very neat
way of passing a function and then
iterable and using the map function to
apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable
so as you've seen we basically passed in
a user defined function
and we applied it to each item in the
list then the map calls the square
function on each
list item and collects all the return
values into a new list
and because map expects a function to be
passed in it also
happens to be one of the places where
lambda functions are
appearing a lot so let's look at the an
example where we do the same operation
using a lambda function
so if you see here i have a lambda
function where
i'm passing it as the function argument
and what this lambda function takes is
some variable x or some argument x it
does its square and it returns that x
and this x is basically going to come
from each element that is present in
this list called items
and when we list down these you will see
it basically does the same thing for us
it creates us list with squared items
now
we can also pass instead of passing
an interval itself we can actually pass
a sequence
of functions and use the lambda function
to perform
a sequence of functions on particular
items so let's look at a new example
a slightly different one so we're going
to use a numpy module for this
don't worry we're just using it to use
the square root function that is present
in the numpy power module
um we will be learning about number in a
later section so um we're going to
import this first
and now i'm going to define three
functions for square cube and square
root
so once i've defined these basically
they're returning the square the cube
root
uh the cube and the square root of some
integer x
and now i'm going to create a list of
these for functions that you've just
seen
um and we're going to use a for loop and
we're going to iterate
through a range from zero to four so and
we're going to pass this
and we're going to say that we want to
apply
some some function we want to apply some
function x and we want to return that
using the snapdraft function
now what values this x will take is
based on whatever functions we've stored
in this variable called fu ncs or funcs
and in fu ncs we have a bunch of
functions called square cube and square
root that we have defined
earlier so what we're going to do is
we're going to apply each of these
functions
to r and r will take the value 0 to 4
and now let's see when we print this
what values we get so if you see here we
get a list
of square root squares cubes and square
roots
for integers 0 1 2
3 and 4. so this is another way of
using the map function and lambda
functions together to apply multiple
different operations
to a bunch of iterables now for our next
example what we're going to do is
we're going to create a function that
basically
what it does is it creates the upper
case of some string that we passed to it
right
so that's what we've done here in this
function called two upper case
so let's define this function now we
have a print function basically which is
going to print each object in a
particular
um it's going to print each element of a
particular object and it's going to
at the end of it and the end of printing
we're going to give a small space
for printing a new line basically so
let's create this also this print
iterator object
now what we're going to do is we're
going to pass a string with
the letters a b and c to this function
and we're going to map
and we're going to apply the upper case
function to this uh string
now if you remember string is also an
iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically
a sequence of one character string a one
character string b and c
so we're going to so we can pass a
string
as a as an iterable to the map function
because it will apply the operations on
each of these characters
so let's see what happens when we do the
upper case function uh we apply the
upper case function using the map using
mapping
to the string a b and c so if you see
it's created me a list with
capital a capital b and capital c as we
had expected
because we have applied the list
function to the map object
now in the next step what we're going to
do is
we're going to do a very similar thing
we're just going to instead of simply
mapping and
creating a list out of it we're going to
store the map object in
a variable called map iterator we're
going to print
what type of object it is and then we're
going to print out each of the elements
using the print iterator function that
we defined here
so let's do this now if you see the
class
the type of object is of class map and
the objects
elements inside the object are a b and c
moving on
let's uh let's look at now an example
where we're going to pass multiple
arguments
um so instead of one iterable we're
going to pass multiple iterables now
and we're going to apply some sort of an
operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created two
uh two two sequences one is a list
of some numbers and another is a tuple
of some numbers
so just to show you let me first copy
this here um yeah
so if you see here i have a list and a
tuple and i'm passing both of these if
you see
to this map function and before that i
have defined a lambda function as the
operation that i'm going to apply
and what this does is it takes two
arguments x and y and it returns the
product of both of these where does it
get x and y from
so the x it gets from this uh this
sequence which is a list
and it takes y from this sequence which
is a tuple so what it's going to do is
going to take
x as 1 and then y is 5 in the first step
and it's going to return the product as
five
then the next step is going to take 2 as
x and then y as 6
and it's going to return the product of
that and we're going to get 12 and so on
we're going to get 21 and then 32
when we and this is these values are
going to be stored in the map iterator
which is a map type object and when we
use the print iterator function it's
basically going to print out
whatever results we got through this
mapping so let's execute this and as you
can see this is a result we got 5
12 21 and 32 which is what we wanted so
the next part
the next function that we're going to
discuss is the filter function now
now a filter function is basically again
it takes two two arguments a function
and a sequence
and a function basically tests if each
element of a sequence is true or not
now a sequence the sequence um so this
filter function will basically take two
arguments so one is the function
and this function is basically going to
test if each element of a sequence is
true or not
and it's going to take another argument
called sequence and this argument
sequence
is the list or the tuple or basically
any sequence
and or iterable that needs to be
filtered and it can be
as i mentioned it can be sets list
tuples or containers of
more iterators and what this function
will return is an iterator
that is already filtered um so let's
look at an example now
so we have this list r which you've
generated which is basically numbers
from minus five to four
so if i create this list here you can
see it will create a list of minus five
to four
now if i wanted to extract only the
values that are lesser than zero
well i can use a for loop and use a if
condition to check this right
so if i did this over here you can see
it
gives me it returns me some list called
result which contains
only the values lesser than 0 which is
basically
checked through this condition what if
there was a
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we
defined a function where we are going to
do the test or we are going to create
the condition
and we are going to pass this to a
particular function and then
apply that particular operation on every
object of some sequence
well just like mapping we have a filter
function to do this
and in this example what we're going to
use is the lambda function which takes
an argument
x and it checks for some condition x
lesser than zero
and where it's going to get the x from
is some sequence r
which which in our case is the numbers
from minus five to four
and the filter will basically create a
filter object type
which contains uh only the objects from
r
that meet this condition that is x is
lesser than zero
and when we use the list operation on
top of it you will see
it creates it results in a list with the
values that have
met my condition so for a second example
what we're going to do is we're going to
create
a list which contains a bunch of letters
and we're going to
only extract the vowels from these bunch
of letters so
let's look at what we have here we have
some letters d a t
j k o p l and we only want the vowels
from this
so we want to filter only the vowels so
we can use that using the filter
function by first of all defining
a function that returns true if a check
is met
that um one of er the letter matches one
of these letters in this list called the
letters
and if it doesn't it returns false so
this is our condition that we've created
once we create this condition uh this
function that checks this
we can pass this function and the
sequence into the
filter function and then we can list out
whatever we get so you can see our
filtered
list contains only a and o which is
basically the only vowels that
are present in our original list finally
we have the reduce function
this reduced function is basically a
func tools it's in the functo's module
of python 3.0
and what the reduce function does is it
applies a function of two arguments
cumulatively to the elements of an
interval and it optionally
it starts with an initial argument and
it returns a single result
so let's first import this function and
once we've imported it let's use it in
this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some lists called numbers right
what if we wanted to take care to get
the sum of each element in this list
well we can iterate over it and store it
in some variable called total in each
step right
this is what we would typically do and
in this step what you can see is the
loop
basically iterates over every valuable
in numbers and accumulates them in total
the final result is the sum of all the
values which is the value of 10 over
here
in this example the variable total is
what we call an accumulator
and we can apply the reduce function to
do the same
task so how do we do it let's first of
all create a function
called my add where we're going to take
two variables uh two arguments and we're
going to return the sum of it
okay so let's uh define this function
and
now we have we have a list called
numbers right which contains one two
three and four
now let's do reduce my add to numbers
now when i do this when i use this
function what it will do is
it will apply the function of my ad it
will take basically
each and every element uh in a sequence
so it will take one and two then add
them together
and then it will create basically what
it will do is it'll take one and two add
them together then we'll have three
so it'll take three and then the next
element which is three again so it'll
create
the sum which is six and then it will
take six and then it will take
the value four and it will give us the
result ten so this is how the reduce
function would work
so this is how it will give us a result
of 10 as you can see here i've simply
used
i've passed this function where i've
defined that i want two
arguments to be passed to a function and
then the return should be basically the
sum
and then i passed a whole list of like
four numbers and i've used the reduce
function to basically do this process
for four numbers
in a step-by-step manner by taking two
at a time subsequently and my result
is as you can see is correct as you can
see here so let's use the lambda
function now to
to do the same topic just do the same
task so what i'm doing now is
i'm going to define a lambda function
and that's the function i'm going to
pass to this reduce
so when i pass this lambda function
which basically takes two
two arguments x and y and it's going to
return the sum of that
as x plus y now where it's going to get
x and y from is in a very
in a very neat manner so it will take
first the first two elements one and two
it will then do the sum and we get three
then it will take that same three
and then take the next object which is 3
again and then give us 6
then it will take 6 and then the next
element which is 4 and then give us 10
and then the reduce function will output
the the single result which is 10 to us
as you can see here so yeah this was our
video
a discussion on map filter and reduce
functions in python
i hope it's a valuable addition to what
you already know about lambda and list
comprehensions
in this video what we will be covering
is certain
abstract data such as structure concepts
and we're going to
also use we're going to implement these
abstract data structures
using basic python techniques and also
we're going to get site introduction
into object oriented programming
to perform these or to create these
abstract data structures
so even consider this as an exercise or
an activity in
op plus some basic python concepts so
let's talk about what stack is
stack being the abstract data structure
that we are talking about over here
so the name stack resembles a pile of
objects right
it can be a stack of papers eight hours
of blocks where adding and removing of
an item occurs only at the top of the
file
so a stack is an abstract linear data
type which is a collection of objects
that supports fast
lasting and first out semantics for
inserts and deletes
and like lists for arrays tags typically
don't allow for random access to the
objects they contain
so you can't just access something by an
index in a stack
you either go from the top or the bottom
of the stack so what we are going to
use is insert and delete operations
which are often called push and pop
respectively
stacks and queues are both linear
connections of collections of items
but however in a queue the least
recently added item is removed first
so it follows a first in first out
approach on the other hand in a stack
the most recently added item is removed
in the beginning
so it's like last in and first out
approach
so a real life example of a stack is a
pile of heavy and precious plates
all kept on top of each other so if you
wish to remove a plate
uh if you wish to add a plate or remove
one you can only do that from the top
and if you want to remove a plate from
the lower bottom of the stack of plates
uh you have to remove from the top one
by one in a practical example of course
a useful real world analogy for
a stack data structures of course stack
of plates it could be a pile of clothes
as well
but uh you typically want to remove or
put everything from on top of the pile
and not
in the middle or the bottom of the pile
so yeah so this
is a visual representation of a stack
where um this this whole it's a linear
collection but whatever we do is usually
uh something to do with the top the
the top most item or the last entered
item of the stack now basic operations
that can be performed in a stack are
mentioned
as uh follows so there's a push
operation which basically adds an item
to the stack
if the stack is full it is called it is
said to be in an overflow condition
there's a pop operation which removes an
item from the stack
it follows a reversed order to pop items
similar to the way
when items are pushed so in that case we
call it an underflow condition
now this peak or top operation which
basically
returns the top element of a stack and
then there's the smd
is empty operation which returns true if
the stack is empty and false if it is
not
now the applications of stacks like
where do we use them
they can be used to reverse a string it
can be used in
expression evaluation expression
conversion
it is used for forward and backward
features in web browsers
it is used in recursive passing in nlpms
and so many other operations are there
and applications for
stacks now let's understand stack
operations so the two most basic
operations are of course
push and pop now when we want to push
what we're basically doing
let's consider an example so let's
consider editing a python file using the
undo feature
in our editor so you we have a clear
understanding of the stack operations
so at first say a new function called
insert is added
the push operation adds the insert
function into the stack so this is a
visual representation
of what we're talking about so we have
this empty list
of this empty stack initially and what
we're going to push on to this
is the insert some function say it's
called
insert or some some object called insert
so once we've done this
this stack looks like this it has an
object called insert right
now a word delete is removed let's look
at the next thing now let's say i
i push something called delete now onto
this right so if i push delete
some object called delete onto this it
goes on top of the insert stack
right because this is a stack everything
occurs in the top like the last
thing that you have added is the first
thing that you will see from the top so
we see delete first in terms of our
example of our python script
assume the script as the whole stack
where we initially had a function called
insert and then we added a function
called delete
and now in the same script we want some
comments
for each of these functions so think of
it as another object that we're going to
add on top of all of this thread
so now we have this python script where
we have the first function
called insert the second function called
delete and a bunch of comments
pertaining to this
and that's the last basically that's the
last object that we added to our
python script now let's perform some pop
operations
so the first like say we did undo now we
have a python script with all of these
things now let's say we pressed undo for
something like say we press undo
well what is the first thing that is
going to go of course it's the last
thing that we entered right and the last
thing we entered was a comment
so when we press undo what gets popped
is the topmost thing which is the
comment
and the comment is now gone and what we
have left in the script is the other two
things
and if we hit undo again well the next
thing that would be removed is the next
most recent thing that was added which
was the delete function
and then if we hit undo again the insert
function will get
removed so this is how the pop function
and the push function works
in terms of stack where i gave you the
example of the undo operation in a
python script
now let's implement a stack in python
there are some basic implementations
and they they are as follows we can use
lists we can use collections.dq
i'll show you what that is and we can
use the custom method which is basically
the oop example that we were talking
about
and there are numerous third-party
package packages which we may or may not
look into
but for the the sake of this uh
particular video
we're going to be looking at these first
three cases in particular
so um let's look at the first option
which is a list built in
now the list the pythons list object
type already has
a decent stack data structure uh
approach as it supports push and pop
operations
by default so let's create a a list
called s
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
append this list with a bunch of strings
so it's
first i'm going to append it with each
sleep and then code so if you see here
if i print my list that i'm going to
treat as a stack these are my objects
right
now if i had to pop from this list your
question would be well
what is the first object that comes out
of this list well
um since we're going to treat this as a
stack and since pop is a stack operation
will pop out or it will remove the the
last most added the
the recent the most recent added object
which was
the string code right so if i had to
execute these
you will see when i do the first pop the
object that gets
popped out is the last thing that was
added which is code now if i did pop
again
it would remove sleep because that was
again the next most recent one
and finally if i did pop again it will
remove eat
uh it's important to note uh oops one
second
so if i do this then if i did pop and
then
okay so the so what happened here was
basically the pop
um okay so i'll tell you what uh so
let's look at an example
where i'm going to be using this so
let's define my stack as some list
s and i'm going to append each sleep and
code to it
so the first object that gets appended
is obviously eat then sleep and then
code
so if i were to pop these objects the
first object that should come out is
code
followed by sleep followed by eat so
let's look at what happens when i
actually try doing it
so let's print out what's in s if you
see
this is basically my my list my list s
now my first pop should remove code as
you can see
my next pop should remove sleep as you
can see finally to remove eat
now the question is what if i did pop
again well an underflow error would
occur
so if i did pop again you see this error
and it says you cannot pop from an empty
list
because i have popped every item which
with three items and the fourth pop will
well there's nothing else to remove from
the list so it gives me an error
our next option for stack implementation
is using the list
using the collections.dq so this is a
base
it contains basically python has a
module called collections it can
comprises of the dq class which is a
double ended queue
that supports inserting and removing
elements from either ends of this
of an object so since dqs support adding
and removing from either side
they can serve both as queues and the
stacks as well so let's import this
dq class and i'm going to create an
object called queue
of class dq and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to do the same thing i'm going
to append each sleep and code
as you can see here let's check what's
in queue well it's a dq objective of uh
it's it's an object of
class dq with the objects each sleep and
code
so again if i did the pop operations it
should remove code sleep and eat
in that order because that's the reverse
order in which i have added them in
right
so let's look at it code gets pop first
then sleep and then eat and of course if
i try to pop even further it will it
should throw me an error because
um there's it's an empty dq now there's
no objects left in it
now the third object is using custom
it's using custom method uh using
classes and objects
so this is basically our example of how
we're going to create a class and
use concepts of basic concepts of object
oriented programming to create our stack
so let's uh let's start working on this
the
so the following stack implementation
assumes that the end of the list will
hold the top element of the stack
as the stack grows basically as the push
operations occur
new items will be added on top of the
list pop operations will manipulate that
same end
so let's create our stack we are going
to create a stack class called stack top
n it will have an initializer which will
basically initialize some
a list called items now once we've done
that we're going to
um so this is basically the str function
um don't worry about this
let's look at these functions which we
are um concerned about
in this particular example so we have a
um after we defined our str function
which is basically what is going to do
is it's going to print the
contents of the stack that we have when
we invoke the print function for a
particular class object
now the custom functions sorry the
custom methods that we have created are
is empty
push pop peak size and display all items
they're very similar to the predefined
uh push pop
peak functions etc so what these will do
is the first function is empties
as the name suggests it's going to check
whether the
list call items is it empty or not if it
is
it will return true otherwise it will
return false based on this check the
push function
it's going to append an item whatever we
pass to the list
items the pop function on the other hand
is going to do the pop operation as we
have
already seen the peak function what it's
going to do
is if you see here it's going to give us
the item
in the last most index so if
if a length of a list is 10 then its
last index is 9 since python is zero
based indexing right
and if we want that last index we can
just do length of that particular list
minus one
and then we can use that as an index for
our list so this is basically what's
happening here
um we're going to check for the uh last
item in the
list called items so yeah penultimately
we have another method called
size this what this will do is basically
return the length of
our object of our list of items finally
we have the method called display all
items which is going to
return the list itself so let's
initialize a stack
we call it s as you can see here let's
execute this first
now we initialize we call it s now we
print
s what it does is well it doesn't see it
doesn't do anything because
what the printf function should do is it
should return us
the stack contents which is nothing
right now because there is we haven't
entered and we haven't added anything to
our list
so we check if it's empty and we see it
is true
it is actually empty so let's start
pushing items into this list
so the first one that we enter uh that
we push into it will be called
will be a string called first then we
push second and then we push third
so let's do this once we have done this
now if we print the uh this object s
it should give us the stack objects or
the stack contents which is
if you see here what i've done is
actually i've actually pushed
uh first second and third twice by
mistake so it basically contains a list
of first second third followed by first
second third again
again this is not an issue we can we can
work with this as well
now let's look at the most recent item
inserted
so since i have entered first second
third followed by first second third
again
so this list contains is basically a
list containing these objects right
like first second third followed by
first second third and
if i were to peak now what was the peak
function the peak function looks into
the last most object
so the peak function should look at the
object that i added
most recently which was the string
called third so if i print this
it should give me third which it does
over here now if i wanted to view the
stack
it's a simple i can iterate through all
of this and print each item
as you can see since i have added it
twice by mistake
uh what i'm going to do or what it's
going to do is it's going to give me
everything
as you can see here so it it basically
what this means is
my stack contains the objects first
second third first second third
similarly i can also use the display all
items to to do the same thing to show
the same thing
as you can see here now i can add a
boolean
so what this what this push will do is
it will add a
boolean object called true so if i push
this to it
now this stack contains a boolean object
called true
as the last object so let's see let's
let's
so if i wanted to see what s contains
now what i can do is
i can do display all items and check
let's see what is there now so if you
see i have my objects here but now
since i added a true object you can see
that over here as well a boolean object
called true now let's print size of
stack
so we use the size function it should be
7
as you can see here now let's let's push
another object so this object is a float
object called 8.4
and once i pushed it and if i want to
display everything
as you can see now i have finally
another object called 8.4 in this
so if i were to pop now what will it pop
it will pop the recent most added
which was the float called 8.4 and if i
did that
as you can see i should get 8.4 here
finally if i were to
display whatever is left here it should
display everything
except the 8.4 which which i have popped
earlier on
as you can see so in this in this other
implementation what i am going to treat
uh the top
as is the beginning of the list so the
zeroth element is going to be my new top
now for the stack
so let's look at uh how things change
because of this
so again i have initialized
a list an empty list and i'm going to
have something
an is empty function to check if the
list is empty i have a push
which will basically now not insert
objects from the last
it will not append objects anymore but
instead what i'm going to do is i'm
going to insert objects to the zeroth
index
of the list item and when i do pop
it won't remove the item in the last
index but it will remove the item at the
zeroth index
similarly peak function will also do the
same thing it will look at the
list from the left hand side so look at
the most the zeroth index
object so that's the peak and then the
size is the same thing it's going to
return the length of the list and
display all items we'll do the same
thing once again
so now i have um once i have created
this let's create an implementation
called stop zero
now is top zero initially empty it
should be true
let's push first second and third now
once i push these
let's look at what was the most recent
item that was inserted which should be
third right
let's view this stack like how does it
look
so if you see here if i print them one
by one it prints third second and first
so even though i've added first second
and third in this order
the items in which i retrieve it is
third second and first and that is
because of how i define the stack where
the top
of the stack is actually the zeroth
index so if i just
did if i did display all items it should
give me a list with third second and
first in that order
so if i execute this you can see this
over here
so again if i did uh just to see again
my peak will basically give me third
now using these concepts that we have
learned let's perform an exercise
um this exercise is going to be where we
are going to write a function
where we're going to reverse the
characters in a string
so let's look at how we're going to
implement this so if you remember this
class
stack top n uh from this from this
earlier
earlier case over here we're going to
use this class to create a
an instance of that class so what we're
going to do is we're going to call it my
stack
and our input string that we're going to
use is called bangalore we're going to
reverse the
characters of bangalore so what we're
going to do is first of all
we're going to push each string each
character of the string
into the stack object using the push
function
and then let's see uh what our
object looks like so as you can see we
have pushed
each character of bangalore into a list
and we've stored it right now for now so
let's initialize
a an empty list and an empty string
now what we're going to do out here is
basically the reversing operation
so as long as my initial list which is
called my stack this object
as long as this object is not empty what
we're going to do is the pop operation
and we're going to keep the adding we're
going to append each
item that we get from the power
population and add it
to our empty string so we're basically
going to create a new string
with letters that we pop from this
particular list which is basically what
is going to do is it's going to pop e
then r and then o and we're going to add
it uh one by one in that order
to and create a new list a new string
out of it so this is how we're going to
do a
reversing string operation so once we
execute this
and we're going to print what is the
reverse string is so if you see here
uh the reverse string in the form of a
list is like this and if the
does the string the string form of the
reverse string is
as you can see here which is basically
bangalore reversed as always i
thank you for watching this video i hope
you learned something about the
stack the abstract data structure in
python
and how we implemented it using basic
python lists
dqs and an object oriented approach to
the same
as always like subscribe and share this
video with your friends so we can reach
out to new learners i hope to see you in
the next video and thank you for
watching and with that we have come to
an end of this particular
python full course tutorial if you have
any queries regarding the topics covered
in this video then please feel free to
leave them down in the comment section
below
our team of experts will be happy to
solve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here
you